motive genuine you always win i just
learned that i learned that [ __ ] with
experience because i feel like there was
like you know when you were on motown it
felt like
you know you come up to the mixer
meeting a couple times and it's almost
like we got to chase a hit so these
[ __ ] will let me drop music
yeah we would like [ __ ] yeah i was i was
exactly what it was i gotta hurry up and
get these folks they want so i can
do me i was chasing a hit i was in that
[ __ ] for success i was in that [ __ ] to
to take care of my family to get money
and get rich i had that on my mind every
day i woke up and i strived as a rapper
i gotta get rich i gotta i gotta make
myself a millionaire i gotta do this i
gotta do that i gotta get i gotta get
these trains i need to go gold i need to
go platinum i gotta be big so that so i
don't waste this opportunity i got this
with this record label and the moment i
uh once they got out this
the situation all that [ __ ] went with it
i let all that [ __ ] go when i let that
[ __ ] go you heard so and the outcome
just is amazing and it still is amazing
i'm still growing like i got a long way
to go from where i want to be i got an
extremely long way to go like you look
at a lot of
a lot of my peers in the rap game and i
ain't just seeing [ __ ] from detroit
just street artists over overall guys
that rap about the street his [ __ ]
really turn [ __ ] got 100 million
around this [ __ ] i got a long [ __ ]
way to go